[bluesy music]
NARRATOR: The Florida softshell
turtle spends most of her life
in water, but has
urgent business on land.
She needs to get to a
delivery room and fast.
She makes it across just
in time and starts to dig.
Her eggs have to be laid on dry
land, and her time has come.
But this she doesn't need--
the attentions of the
worst midwife in the world.
The crow's anxious to
speed the process along.
The turtle knows what
the crow's after,
and she has a decision to make.
She has to stop laying
her eggs to save them.
[crow caws]
It's too late for the
first unfortunate egg.
But the distraction gives her
a chance to head for shelter,
still carrying dozens more.
Sometimes the good of the many
outweighs the good of the one.